こんにちは
いやー今で電池が切れそうでちょっと後ろに立っしなきゃからちょっと体があったまっ
ています
あの
あれこれいける
hey
と早い
はいえーこんにちは皆さん改めまして
の際のは確かですあのデザイナーです
あのまあデザイナーという仕事がどういう仕事かっていうのはこの内のデザイナーの人
がいるかもしれないし
たぶんここにより多くの人が一応デザインに興味を持ってくれてんじゃないかなって
いう前提て
今日はデザインの話をしようかなと思ってます
あのまあいろんなデザインを今までしてきてんですけど
影響そんないろいろやってきたよっていうデザインについて
するつもりあんまりありません
ダラググってください
何をやったのかただ皆さんと話したいのは
僕デザイナーだから
いいデザイナーになりたいですね皆さんも
its all スプレーディンというこのイベントに出ている限りは
すごいアイデアメーカーになりたいとかすごくいい発想を持ちたいとか何か社会発明を
したいとかそういう人たちだと思っています
で
このねデザインというテーマは本当に深淵のテーマで
何かが生まれる時に必ずデザインがそこにあるわけなんですけどちょっとね
じゃあここから一緒にちょっと目つぶってください
あの
僕と一緒にね
今から
ベストなデザイナーになるためにはどういう思考プロセスでなんてどういう考え方でか
な
どういう考え方でアイディアを捕まえに行けばいいのかどうやったらいいアイディアが
出るのかってことを今からちょっと一緒に念じながらはいちょっと名開けてください
話をちょっとしていきたいと思ってます
いいデザインってなんでしょうね
あの良いデザインというのは要するに良い形をつくることですよ
世の中で要するに酵素の形が例えば皆さん一緒に座っているでしょう
その形て紀元前おそらく2000年くらい前にできている形でそれが今までそれがいい
形だから残ってきているものなわけですよそれすごいことじゃないですか
ねえ
あのこれ進化系統受信数ですよあの動物もね
その形が要するにその高は足の形とかどういう形をしていたらどういう風に世の中に
残っていけるのかということを探しながら自分たちの形を進化させてきました
このプロセスとね僕らがデザイナーがいい形なんだ
このプロジェクトにハマってるこのプロジェクトにふさわしいこれが存続する形でなん
だというふうに願うことって僕すごく実は似てるというか同じことかもしれないって
ちょっと思っているんですよ
あのねぇ僕この間あの神坐で個展をしてたんですけどその時のテーマがこの進化と
デザインの関係だったんですこれもあのねたくさんチョコエッグとかわかるかな
たくさんの動物の高人形を集めて作った立体も進化角も ok なんですけど
あのこれとか見ながらね考えてるといろんなこと思うわけ
で今日は8個ぐらいちょっと
そういうふうに進化をずっと考えている中で気付いたデザインと進化の関係ないし
進化から見える僕らが
いいアイディアを考えるときにこの物差しで考えたらいいアイデアが浮かんじゃうん
じゃないかということをちょっとみなさんにシェアしたいと思って
後に立ってます
さっきの橋んかつでしょエボリューショなり一塁ね
芯数
進化ズってねこれ自分で進化図を書いたことがある人ってここに入らいらっしゃらない
かもしれないです
僕書いてみたんですよ是則もも進化数
左に人がいて
車輪が紀元前さん紀元前35世紀にへカヌーみたいなものは紀元前60世紀に生まれた
という風になってるんだけど
こういうふうにねあのあらゆるものが今まで進化してきてるんだけど
この進化を俯瞰するっていうことって実はほとんどなんていうのかな例えば文化人類学
とかでやってることがそうなんだけど
でもデザインという意味であんまりされてきてないんですよ携帯電話の新勝つとかって
発見できないでしょ
でもこれをやる
音が実は未来の乗り物を考える上でめっちゃ大事なことだなってこれやりながら気づい
た理由
何か新しいことを考えるときにその分野の進化図を書いてみようと思ってください
さて二つ目
あのねこの時ね僕ねもう一個やってみたことがあるの
これ iphone ねみんなが好きなスマートフォン
スマートフォンに
融合されてしまったものをいっぱい集めてみたわけタイプライターとか
菅地図を
漫画とか占いとかゲームとか
なんかまぁオーディオオーディオ何か曲容量
電話
カメラ
で
まあ膨大なわけですよこれらが全部あの板に入ってるわけ
すごいことですよね
次何が入りますかね
次に何が入るのかこれが携帯電話が進化するということなんだと思う
だから何かを融合させるということはアイディアの本当に基板中の基盤なんだと思い
ます
生物も例に漏れず例えばねここにミトコンドリアンって書いてある
あれは実は僕らのすべての細胞に入ってるまぁ
細胞の一部なんだけど
大元はねぇ別の微生物だところなんですよ
辛いも何が言いたいかっていうと皆さんの細胞1個1個に皆さんじゃない生物が入って
るって考えてくださいってことなんですよ
そうやって融合してできてってるってすごいことだぜと進化の中でも融合を使う
どんどんいきます
解剖
あのねぇ
例えばリバー1000 j ライニングという言葉があるけど僕もちょっと分解してみ
たんですよ右が扇風機で左がオリーブの木年
分解しててみるとそれぞれのパーツそれぞれの形が理由でできてんのかってのがなんと
なくわかってく
そして人工物というのはやっぱり自然物に比べてはるかに効率が悪いなったことも
わかる
人工物は100種類以上のパーツがあったけど
オリーブは基本的に4種類ぐらいの発しかなかったでも意味や関係性はすごく大きい
でしょうオリーブの方が
でもこうやって分解していくとなんでこの袋ついてんだろう
なーんでこのクーラー付いてんだろうとか言って言いながら僕らは自分たちの身体を
理解していたです
何かを理解するときに僕らを開ける分かるとは分けることかも知れませんねそれ5件で
言うと本当にそうなんだそうなんですけどだから分解をして理解するってのはコレ
一つすげー大事なことだなと
さあ次々いきますやった4つ目
8ね変形
あの ipad と iphone って基本的にはほら変形してるだけでしょ
同じものが
魚もですよ
魚が入って変形しているだけですよ同じ木のか
猿もそうです
3時が人間だけど変形してるだけですよどれぐらいの骨のうち坂
飛行機もそうですねー
変形させるだけで同じ機能のものを別の環境や状況に最適まあま最適というよりはあの
適切な状態にしていくかぺ記者生存というふうに生命の進化なんかだと言うんだけど
いう状況をつくっていくのはどういうことなんだろうっていうのこれもまたといいです
よ
なさんが持っている皆さんがあり北に持っているものをただでかくする
ただ小さくするただちょっと形を変えるだけでどんな事が起こるんだろうというふうに
僕らが想像することができたらひょっとしたらそれだけで発明ができるかもしれない
あとねちょっとね集めてみたのが色とテクスチャー
ザラザラ感ツルツル感ペク者ですね
一生懸命集めてみたのが蝶の標本
蝶の標本と世の中に存在する綺麗な髪に輝のこうやって頑張って
さあしていったんですねそっくり中身を
でそういうふうにするとね結構面白いことが分かったのが
なんかこいつらの中で
ホラー
エルメスみたいなやついないですか
ティファニーみたいなやついないですか
実は腸がやっていることと僕たちがブランディングと言ってやっているグラフィック
って言ってやってることって
=なんじゃねーのかと思うんですよ
超の方がうまくいっているかもしれないですよね
これって何だろうか色を形を変えるってすごくある意味では投資コストの少ない話です
よ進化においては色だけですから
それを使っていろんな状況に怖がらせたり
アトラクティブになったりそうやって生物は生き延びていく
じゃあ我々が発明するものはどうでしょう
次
うんとねー
二知りなことなんだけどね
何か特定の美しさの方っていうのがどうやら世の中にあるみたいなんですよ
これは線香花火よね
知ってるやつでしょ
これ何かわかりますか
これ何か知ってる人入っ
ちょっとだけいる
これはインターネットです
似てないですかフラクタル上のパターンが枝分かれして
クラスターに分かれてなんでこれらが似てるんでしょうね
そしてなんでこれを僕らを美しいと思ったり最適だと思ったりするんでしょうね
これ蜂の巣ですよ
ハチノスと
これみんなが知ってるやつですね
なんでにてるんでしょうねぇ
採蜜配置たんか言うんだけどないし
ボロノイってパターンの究極的に理想的な形でな六角形の配置になっていくんですけど
そういうふうにこう何かを何かたくさんのものがギュッと詰まってしまったり一番密接
にこう
埋められるカタチをコー探すとこういう形になってくるんだけど
何でなんでしょう
これ何か知ってる人いるからこれはねチューリングパターンというものです
シマウマとかのパターンとかは実は今数学的に解析ができるんですけど自然界の
パターンはこんなふうになるそうなんですよ
計算にかけるとなんかこのチューリングパターンの応用でだいたい子シマウマの模様と
か
あの砂漠の子
波なミートした模様とかそういったものはだいたいこのパターンの計算して出てる
らしいんですけど
これキースヘリングですよ
ねえ
なんでなんとなくそうなのかっていうのわかんないけど僕らが普遍的にいいなとか素敵
だなって思うものに対して何を僕らは感じているのかとか
あそこの裏に潜んでいるパターンは何なのかっていうことを僕らが知っているとその
パターンに寄り添えるんじゃないのかなって思うんですよね
っすそれもも多分デザイナーとして探しているんだと思うんですよ
理想的な形なんてないのかもしれないんだけど
でもその理想に近づくための手段としてそういったものを学んでるって事はすげー大事
なことだなって思って日々
デザインをしています
僕ら釣りね力学力
永江ねあと二つ
これはねー
ヒモを垂らしたカーブですよ妹ぴゅーんと来たラストこういうカードできる
これはねかてなりカーフっていうんだけど綺麗じゃないですか
ねえ
不思議なことに猫のかてなりカーブっていうカーブが
らプロダクトデザイナーなんとなく知ってんだけど人類が一番綺麗だと思うカーブ
らしいんだよね
俺は不思議なんだけど
でもまあ考えてみれば僕らが重力空間に生きてるからなんとなくそうなっちゃうんだと
思うんですけど
でこういうこのカテなりカーブを応用してかつて建築を建てた人がいます
の模型です
誰かわかる人がいるかな
その人の名は
アントニオ買うでい
サグラダファミリアっていうあの建築はかてなりカーブの連続でで言っている
たても
なんですね
あれは一人の天才が作った物って僕らを持っているかもしれないんだけど
でも実は一人の天才が見ようとしていたのは自分の表現ではなくて自然界の中にはどこ
美しいパターンが潜んでるんだろうかってことだったと思うんですよね
それがだからこの場合は重力に拮抗する一番美しい形だったわけ
最後にね
流れについてい
これたぶんね一番ねーわかんなくて僕の中で一番深いテーマだなぁと思っているんです
これはの僕が作った後ですけどただ砂が流れるだけのアートです
ガラスとガラスの間を砂が流れている
こんなふうにね
なんかね
流れているのをずーっと見つめているだけで
そこに
木みたいなパターンを
発見したり
何か生きているようなパターンを発見することがあるわけですよ
あの最新の
高層有効進化ないし造形
まあ生物の形態学っていうジャンルがあるんですけどその形態学の最新の概念ではどう
やら生物は流れが
流れがスムーズになる方向に熱力学的に力学的に流れがスムーズになる方向に進化を
するんだっていうことを提唱している科学者があります
つまり僕らが何かを作る時にその作ったものが果たして
もっとうまく世の中を流すことができるようになるだろうかっていうことっていうのは
これ結構大事なイマジネーションだなーって思うんですよ
何か発明をしたら繋がってない人と人が繋がるとか何か提案をしたらその提案によって
今まで越えられなかった壁が越えられるとか
それによって席が
こうせき学校を切られて凝った張って水が流れ込んでいくようなイメージ
そういった新しい流れを生むって本当に文字通り
どういう形があったらそこに新しい流れが生まれるのかってことなんだと思う
んですよね
その流れを作るということがねおそらく
イノベーションを起こすってことなんだと思うんですよ
このさっきの進化ずに戻って
左上の方を見ると
人が立っています
あそこにいるのが皆さんです
あそこに立っているのが皆さんで皆さんが作ったものを僕らが作ったものが
自分たちをどうを次の
ステージ次の流れ次の進化された姿に持っていくかということが日々デザイナーが日々
inventor が日々のベータが取り組んでいることだと思う
だから僕らは何かを作るっていうことを何かを提案するということを通して進化しよう
としている
たぶんここに集まっている人たちもそういった進化を求めて自分の進化かもしれないで
もその進化はひょっとしたら
ひょっとしたらものすごくうまくいけば人類の進化もしれん
そういったことを想像しながら本当にいいデザインを作るって何なのかっていうのを
これからも皆さんと考えていけたらすごい美味しいです
さて今日のお話はここまで
ありがとうございました
[拍手]